what's your name what's my name yeah
Mohammed his actual name Stuart selwitz
seen in this now viral video repeatedly
harassing a food vendor in Manhattan if
we killed 4,000 Palestinian kids you
know what it wasn't enough as shocking
as his words are who he is perhaps even
more so he is a former high-ranking US
state department official he once worked
in the Israel and Palestinian Affairs
office H away go back where you came
from hate speech like this is on the
rise in the US it is a su Supremacy
mentality a Jewish Supremacy Ray TAA has
seen it firsthand he recently took his
young son to a protest calling for a
ceasefire in Gaza because we are right
and you m they knew they were on tape
yeah it goes to their Hubers they didn't
they didn't care they felt that they
were they could say whatever they
want it went f further two men poking
and pushing
himl
musl when police arrived T says they did
nothing we asked the police to explain
they did not respond to Al
jazer social media in the US has been
filled with videos of protests some
violent others silent don't want to give
your name you're so proud to do that
many Jewish students on College campuses
say they've been targeted as well they
were saying things that were very
violent and things that were so
anti-semitic calling for the final
solution Jewish genocide I know a lot of
my friends are nervous to wear their
starve David necklaces um to wear like
AAW there is a growing prop Palestinian
movement in the US seen in marches and
rallies across the
country Tai says he will continue to
protest he believes this time something
is Shifting in the US we are going to
see over the next year or two or three a
major kind of shift hopefully where
where the pro-israel voice is countered
with a pro- Justice and pro peace voice
recently a committee in the US House of
Representatives held a hearing on the
rise of anti-Semitism on college
campuses it's
infuriating and unbelievable they have
not held one on the rise in islamophobic
attacks Patty Gohan Al jazer Montgomery
County Maryland
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer